JONATHAN HSEU: Hi, I'm Jonathan.
A lot of you are probably
running a lot of infrastructure
already in your
organization or you
want to think about running
various other pieces
of infrastructure.
And I'm going tell you about
TensorFlow fits into that.
So, the clicker--
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
OK, thank you.
So first, I'm going to talk
about all the steps you
go from training to serving
a model in production.
And it typically involves
these three steps.
Usually, the raw data that you
have isn't good for training
yet, so you have to do some
form of data preparation.
After that, you do training
and then you serve your model.
So, for data preparation,
there are three essential steps
that are involved
in data preparation.
So you'll import the data
from various sources.
This might be Hive,
MySQL, and so on.
You'll typically perform
some sort of pre-processing
on the data.
They'll compute
aggregates or do joins
and then you'll export the file
in the file format supported
by TensorFlow and I'll
explain that a bit later.
So, a lot of people have been
using typically these three
things for doing this process--
SPARC, Hadoop, MapReduce,
or Apache Beam.
And it works well with
all these at the moment.
And as a visual
example, we have--
you're feeding in
data from MySQL.
Say it's user data.
And you have data in Hive.
An example might be web
impressions or web clicks.
You want to join that
data, compute aggregates
like user data per region.
Often, you'll do vocabulary
generation, particularly
if you're using embeddings.
Vocabulary generation
essentially
means, like, mapping from
words to IDs and the IDs map
to an embedding
layer-- embedding.
And then after that,
you'll typically
have a training test split.
And after this process,
you'll output to a file format
that TensorFlow understands.
And why might you
want to do this?
So, the input file format
they use with TensorFlow
actually matters quite a bit.
So, one example is, suppose
you're training inception
on P100 GPUs.
You want to keep
the P100 saturated.
Actually, one of the
most important things
you can do to make
that work well
is work on your input pipeline.
And that involves
working with cues.
There are tutorials on
the TensorFlow website.
But specifically in this case,
I'll talk about file formats.
Some file formats are
faster than others.
We have specifically
optimized the path
for working with tf.Example
and tf.SequenceExample protocol
buffers.
SequenceExample
is typically used
when you're training
with RNNs and tf.Records
is a TensorFlow
specific file format
that we use with TensorFlow.
And this is by far the fastest.
We use this internally and
we've optimized this path
pretty well.
Additionally,
TensorFlow also natively
has ops to support reading from
various file formats like CSV,
JSON, fixed record length files.
We have upcoming
support for Avro.
So you can use those.
Those are a little slower,
but since they're native ops,
they actually work pretty well.
More commonly,
people, if you, like,
read examples of
TensorFlow code on the web,
people will be feeding
data directly in Python.
And this is by far
the most common.
It's the easiest
to experiment with.
It also has the
most flexibility,
meaning that you can use
any file format that Python
natively can understand and
then convert it to numpy arrays,
which can be fed as
tensors in TensorFlow.
It's also useful for settings
like reinforcement learning.
But it's also the
slowest option.
So if you're running
experiments, this makes sense.
But if you're trying to
productionize a pipeline
and you care about
training speed,
then you might want to consider
switching to the first option.
OK, I'd like to mention
actually why it's a bit slower.
There are two things
that are involved--
reading from specific
file formats in Python
itself may not be too fast.
So you have that part.
And then when converting from
new pi arrays to TensorFlow
tensors, there is
a copy involved
and that induces
additional overhead.
So I've recommended
tf.RecordSupport.
Hopefully at this
point, you're convinced.
And how well does it work?
So, Apache beam, as
of a few weeks ago,
actually has native support
for this file format.
But a lot of you aren't
running Apache Beam
and you'll be running
Hadoop MapReduce and SPARC
jobs already.
And you just want to use that.
So if you go to the ecosystem
repository in the TensorFlow
GitHub organization, we have
code to work with TF records
there.
Note that I didn't mention
protocol buffers at all.
Protocol buffers actually
has native support
for a lot of languages
you would be using.
OK, so now that you've
exported this training data,
you want to go to training.
There are two common
ways of doing training.
One is say you have a GPU
on your desktop or laptop.
You want to do local training.
This works well for the specific
cases of debugging or working
with small order data sets.
But as Megan mentioned
in the intro talk,
distributed training--
like, 64 GPUs,
you actually get a 58x speed up
in images processed per second
if you run on
distributed starting
with 64 GPUs versus one GPU.
So you train much faster.
And for a lot of people
in your organization,
this could mean the
difference of taking a month
to train a model
versus taking a day.
And the feedback loop
is pretty important
to make machine learning work
well in your organization.
So, there are two
essential components
if you want to start
with distributed
training in your organization.
Derek was talking
about cluster managers.
We know organizations that
have been using all of these
to make a distributed
TensorFlow work well.
So we'd recommend any of these.
By Hadoop here, I
mean Hadoop Yarn.
And so we actually have
configuration examples
for Kubernetes and
Mesos specifically
in the ecosystem repository.
So if you're already running
that, then you can get
started pretty quickly that way.
But in addition to
a Cluster Manager,
you should also be running
distributed storage.
Derek was talking about
this a little bit,
but these are the ones
that we work with.
We added HDFS support
in TensorFlow 11.
TensorFlow also
has native support
for reading from
Google Cloud Storage,
and if you're running on
Amazon's cloud service,
then users have reported it
working well with Amazon EFS.
So, the reason you would want
to run distributed storage
is mostly for two reasons--
for your input
data so each worker
can read from a single source
and for output for your model--
so, for checkpoints in
the exported model itself.
So, containers are
completely optional
but highly recommended.
So, containers isolate your
workers from their environment.
And one reason this is useful
is because certain jobs
might have certain
version dependencies that
might differ from other jobs.
And a specific example
here is eventually,
we'll release TensorFlow 2.0.
Senseful uses
semantic versioning,
and at 2.0, we may make some
backwards incompatible changes.
And suppose you want to
upgrade to TensorFlow
2.0 in your organization.
Then the containers
make it much easier
to do gradual updates
because you don't have
to update every job at once.
You can just update jobs.
You can pin the jobs to a
particular TensorFlow version
and update each one one by one.
So, getting started with
containers makes sense.
Docker is supported in
both Mesos and Kubernetes
and we recommend that.
So, as a refresh for what
Derek was talking about,
I'm going to show you what
distributed trading code looks
like as a refresh of
what Derek mentioned
and what configuration involves.
So, there are essentially two
types of jobs that you have--
parameter servers and workers.
And Derek mentioned that
the most common setup
and the setup that we recommend
is between graph replication.
And in that case, workers
operate completely
independently.
So the workers don't
necessarily talk to each other
or even know about each other.
They only communicate with
the parameter servers.
And for that, Derek
actually showed this but
across multiple slides.
This is the code involved if
you're using core TensorFlow.
With the higher level
APIs, a lot of this
goes away and becomes
much fewer lines of code.
But in essence,
your Cluster Manager
specifies all the other
parameter servers and workers
that this worker must
communicate with.
You start a server.
If you're a parameter
server, you just stop there.
But if you're a
worker, then you need
to assign variables
to parameter servers
and set the worker device
so that this graph belongs
on this particular worker.
So, configuration really
depends on which cluster manager
and which distributed
storage system you chose.
We have examples, again, in
that repository dimension,
that ecosystem repository.
And we're adding
more and feel free
to contribute any that you know
that work well in your existing
infrastructure.
Additionally, I'd
like to mention
that Yahoo! recently open
sourced code to run on SPARC.
And why is this useful?
Because you might
think that SPARC
is like a data
processing framework.
Why would it be useful to run
on SPARC rather than a Cluster
Manager?
So, SPARC actually has support
for running on Mesos, Yarn
or in standalone
mode, and a lot of you
will already be running
SPARC in your organization.
And this actually might be the
easiest way to get started.
And for sure, it's difficult
to run distributed TensorFlow
on Hadoop Yarn.
And for sure, it's
much easier to get
started if you're running
SPARC on top of Yarn
than to try to run distributed
TensorFlow on Yarn directly.
So I'd recommend this
in specific cases
where you're already
running SPARC.
And Dandelion talked
about TensorBoard.
You might wonder, how do you use
this with distributed training?
So, with distributed
training, typically, you
have output which are
summaries and events that
go to a directory
that you specified
on distributed storage.
All you need to do
to run TensorBoard
is run the TensorBoard
command and point it
to that distributed
storage directory.
It will start in
HTTP server locally
that you can just look at.
You can look at your losses.
You can go through the
embedding visualizer
and how that stuff works.
So, like, I've skipped
a lot of steps here.
Like, suppose you
need to do hyper
parameter tuning and so on.
But suppose you're already
done with all of that
and you're happy
with your model.
You want to export it and
serve it in production.
So currently, we have two
common ways of doing that,
but in the long
term, it will be one.
We highly recommend
you go with SaveModel.
It's going to be the standard
file format for TensorFlow
going forward.
And the advantage to
SaveModel over everything else
is that it includes
all the assets
you need to serve your
model in production.
I mentioned that
vocabularies are
pretty common for embeddings and
you use a specific vocabulary
at training time.
You want to make sure to use
the exact same vocabulary
and serving time.
It includes all
those files for you.
So the other
advantage to SaveModel
is it's a bunch
of graphs and you
can specify which one you want
to use for a particular use
case.
GraphDef right now is pretty
common in particular uses,
particularly on mobile.
So, in the mobile
example, you typically
freeze your variables
into constants
in your TensorFlow graph.
The advantage to
GraphDef right now
is that GraphDef is actually
a protocol buffer which
accesses like a single file.
So you only have to
distribute a single file.
That's much easier to deploy.
But that advantage
is going away.
As of recently, you can
also freeze a SaveModel.
So hopefully, you've
exploited the SaveModel.
You want to serve it.
Noah-- the subsequent talk is
actually going go much more
into TensorFlow serving and
I'm only going to talk about
the top two here--
TensorFlow serving and
in process TensorFlow.
So, these are both options
for serving your TensorFlow
model after you've exploited it,
but they are quite different.
TensorFlow serving,
in its typical mode,
runs as a separate service
that you make RPCs to.
So, why might you choose
one over the other?
So, Noah's going to go
much more in depth here,
but serving a model actually
has a lot of hidden nuance
that you might not be aware of
when you just think about it.
So, if you're just applying
a model as a one off,
then it might make sense to
just use in-process TensorFlow.
Flow
But if you think about--
like, suppose you
have a job that
trains every day on
new data and you want
to serve a new model every day.
How might you start
serving that new model?
You can think about it.
There's like two basic
ways that might happen.
In your server, you can
unload the completely unload
the old model and then
wait for that to finish,
wait for all requests to
finish, and load your new model.
This is memory efficient
because you only
have one model loaded
at a single time.
Or, you can simultaneously
load the new model
while it's running and
double your memory usage.
tf.Serving offers that as
a configuration option.
Additionally, for
efficiency, particularly
if you're serving on GPUs,
you want to batch your inputs.
This also has some
benefit on CPUs,
but particularly if
you're serving on GPUs,
you want a batch to
fully utilize your GPUs.
As you can imagine,
there's some nuance
to how you want to
batch, particularly
in low latency settings.
So, tf.Serving handles that.
Also, if you're serving
multiple models,
isolation between those models--
they're going to contend
for hardware resources
and there's some difficulties
in isolating between them.
It's particularly intensiveful.
You have to think
about which threads--
like, how to size
thread pools and so on.
You don't have to think
about that if you're
on TensorFlow serving at all.
So, that's the next talk.
Now that I've explained all
the benefits, you're like, OK,
then why not just use
that all the time?
Why should I use in
process TensorFlow at all?
So, in process TensorFlow is
actually the standard mode
for certain things,
specifically if you're
running on a mobile device.
Pete actually went over this.
Basically, you have a TensorFlow
session and you run it.
If you're running
batch inference-- like,
if you already have a TensorFlow
model, you have a ton of data
and you want to run inference
over that data using Beam
or SPARC, then it's
much better to just use
in process TensorFlow than
to start another tf.Serving
service.
There's the specific case
of very strict latency
requirements where
you don't want
to do the RPCs back and forth
with TensorFlow serving,
but this is a very rare case.
Usually, the latency
involved there is very small.
Operationally speaking,
it's much easier
to run one service
than to run two.
So if you want to
simplify your deployments,
that's also a reason to do this.
But regardless of
which one you choose,
the first two steps between
them is practically the same.
You want to export your state
model, make it accessible,
and then you have to write
the code to do inference.
And I'll show you what that
looks like in a moment.
For in process TensorFlow,
you have the additional step
of linking to the TensorFlow
shared library, which
we actually distribute.
And you can see that in our
Go and Java instructions
and you can just
download it right there,
or you can build it yourself.
So, here's the Go example of
what inference looks like.
It's actually not
too much code at all.
And actually, if you go to
the Go repository on GitHub,
you can actually see
real inception code
that works in Go.
So, what it involves is first
loading your saved model.
You pass the directory
that the save model is in.
As I mentioned before,
save models involve
multiple TensorFlow graphs.
So, after you specify
the directory,
there is a list of--
set of tags that you
can use to specify
which TensorFlow
graph you want to load.
When you execute your
model, all of you
are probably already familiar
with TensorFlow sessions
if you've ever used
TensorFlow at all.
It's essentially the same
thing as the Python API
but in another language.
You take a tensor.
Here, we have a batch of images.
And you run your TensorFlow
model using that tensor.
And as output, you
get probabilities
for each classification for
each image in the batch.
And you do something with it.
So I showed Go there.
Jeff mentioned that we support
a ton of different languages.
These languages are all on our
TensorFlow GitHub repository.
So you can actually just
go to the TensorFlow GitHub
repository and start
using any of these.
All of these
languages can actually
be used to build and
execute TensorFlow graphs,
But a common question is, can
any language besides Python
be used for training?
And the answer is a bit nuanced,
but the short of it is no.
And the reason is because a
lot of the supporting libraries
like the training libraries,
the high level APIs, optimizers,
the RNN library, all of those
are only available in Python
at the moment.
So I would personally
recommend that you only
do training in Python, but
you can do inference in any
of these other languages.
The instructions for
using the shared library
are in the readmes that are
associated with each language.
So you can either download
it or build it yourself.
I won't go into too
much detail here.
So, as a summary--
so, these are the basic steps.
You're probably running
infrastructure already
around it.
The point I want
to emphasize here
is that, especially if
you have a lot of data
in your organization,
you really should
be thinking about how to make
distributed trading work well
and what you should
be running to do that.
As Megan said, there's
like a 58x speed
up when running
on 64 GPUs and you
can imagine what
kind of effect that
would have on the engineers
working with TensorFlow,
in training TensorFlow models.
And thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]